vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel d'un qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr bienvenue
aux sans filtre le podcast on parle de
ce qu'on veut que nos invités dati site
super h 45 mois d'une planque
cette semaine le podcast est présenté
par revivre smoothie investissent pour
la première fois une commandite
moi je suis un grand consommateur de
vishnou tisser des petits smoothie vous
gardez congelée d'un congélateur qui
viennent en petites capsules professeur
dans un shaker vous mettez votre liquide
de choix de l'aude et les végétaux et
c'est là dedans on check un peu ces
prêts à lyon des smoothies des jules
verne et smoothies aux fruits ont des
smoothies protéines et tous au végétal
tous au bio vous voulez faible fait même
les faire livrer chez vous avec la
livraison gratuite au québec et en
ontario
donc allez voir sur leur site sur leur
site avait un souci avec six points
comme j'imagine bien ce cyclo nord-sud
gelé pas ici mais on a un code promo
pour vous qui est sans filtre podcast 10
tout cela en un mot qui en 10 % de
rabais toute façon on va mettre le site
dans la description du podcast le fait
que juste cliquer là dessus
aller inscrire notre code promo pour 10%
de rabais c'est vraiment de la bombe
dollars de rabais pardon donc merci la
gagne derviches mutis et je faire
apprécier collaborer avec nous sinon
cette semaine dans un paradis non on est
reçu rose est liée à sa lutte ou buzz
intégra meuse influence euse et otis de
livres de recettes tout comme toi parce
qu'elle goût j'ai dit révélé son vrai
nom désolé non à l'ours adet plus grands
why rosalie qui était parfait n'espère
sparco lesparre drolet smartphones on a
parlé de
de son parcours académique que où elle
étudie qu'est ce cas là comment qu'elle
appelait la cuisine du son on a parlé du
système d'éducation générale ses points
forts et ses points forts selon noah
vinh non-experts bien sûr de parler de
parler en fait raconté un petit peu une
pause plus difficile qu'elle ait eu des
pressions n'ayons pas peur des mots puis
maintenant ça vaut mieux donc on la
félicite que l'on l'encouragent
non mais justement comment calais réussi
à s'en sortir puis qu'est ce que fait
aussi kaka s'est rendu en épuisement
comme ça et on a parlé de ses projets
futurs ou si on a parlé de sa carrière
de youtube buzz de youtube en général
c'est super ce n'est pas la conversation
avec une fille vraiment le fun belles
rencontres
ouais vraiment vraiment c'est le fun
c'est le fun que les gens s'ouvrent sur
le podium parce que j'ai l'impression
que beaucoup de monde comme on se
reconnaître dans les problématiques qui
rosalie un véhicule dans la dernière
année là je pense que je pense que
beaucoup de monde qui vont s'y
reconnaître donc écouter se laisser des
commentaires participer à la
conversation
abonnez vous à nos chaînes est vraiment
beaucoup de monde qui commence à nous
écouter sur spotify j'ai l'impression
que je défends est entrain de jack et le
marché des podcasts au québec
mondialement s'était déjà fait mais j'ai
l'impression que parfois ils sont en
train de tranquillement voler tout le
monde donc ça lui les nouveaux qui nous
suivent sur ce portefeuille les sinois
writing là dessus si puis sinon
abonnez-vous à notre paix tu renonces en
vo justement shoot impétueux en au
moment où est-ce qu'on veut pas ou parce
qu'on répond aux questions de nos
abonnés pétrole et qu'ils allaient voir
là dessus et sans plus attendre en fait
on vous laisse apprécier cette
conversation là avec rosalie donc bon
podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
rosalie commence à vous et ça veut bien
ça oh bien sûr bien ouais
comment comment tu vis là la situation
actuelle classique question des débuts
de grâce est question d une part parce
que c'est ce qu'on enregistre vraiment
on essaie d'enregistrer d'ici la journée
le avant qu'on le sorte parce que pour
avoir les résultats de l'été les
réponses au temps où est ce que ça se
passe
parce que ça évolue tellement vite mais
je te dirai qui et est déjà une coupe
d'un jour n'est qu'un bref épisode dans
le fond là pour ceux qui pour ceux qui
savent pas où et bac quand ça a commencé
oui on est de confinement l'ecofin
ensemble et tout ça faisait peut-être
une semaine et qu'il y avait commencé à
a demandé aux gens de respecter
confinement qui est dans les monts de
fait le choix de se mettre ensemble dès
le début est un choix toujours plus
celui là mais la magie culine au pénal
des types j'en ai vu personne on est
resté juste nous deux c'est ensemble
qu'ils ont fait des fouilles sous la
tension est effectif depuis quelques
années c'est à nous y aurons de
redoubler de prudence parce que l'info
vanessa l'a fait de la part importante
des respecté toutes les règles du jeu
ils menaient est posée par exemple
masqué on veut pas thiam a dit comme
puis comment ça a été cette étude
seulement en groupe et ça allait
vraiment bien et est en fête et six mois
plus tard on s'était pas mis ensemble on
n'est pas sûr on n'allait vraiment pas
bien et isolé tout seul
complètement saoul et le meilleur
mouvement il faut pas sous-estimer
l'aspect santé mentale de tous le thé
wit
peut-être que tu sais même pas où vous
êtes isolé donc c'est pas plus risqué
mais justement retire les dommages
arrêter vraiment plus
si chacun bosse mais je sais que des
gens qu'il gère très bien les allemands
complet seul mais moi il en a aucune
à ces sites offrent car même être sur le
pied et en plus en plus acquis l'été qui
arrive c'est comme si c'est juste place
c'est calme en vain qui agace ou pardon
ou est-ce que vous êtes complètement moi
je suis moi j'suis solo de l'eau à la
partie si le depuis le début le chantier
je peux je plonge peu de seine a fait le
fait que ça va le même si je pense que
j'aurais eu ro faux site seul j'essaie
d'imaginer
c'est justement le t71 foot qu'aucun
contact du maillot que personne à qui
parler aucun serov
euh je suis quand même l'honneur dans
ville puis jamais vraiment besoin d'être
en groupe
pitch un gamer effective et je me suis
dit ça va participer mais là ça commence
à être longue si je commence à réaliser
que même si je le dis je faisais pas
d'activités sociales à tous les jours
j'en faisais quand même plus que ce que
je croyais
c'est quand tu le poc tu réalises que
fuck tu disais que tu étais quand même
occupé de ces temps-ci ccoty fait
l'enfant qu'est ce que t'as que beau
temps et ben en fait comme me garder
occupés
c'est la seule chose qui justement qui
est menteur le fait que je suis donné
prime projet depuis le début de la
quarantaine
le chercheur vélo et fait que je
commence à faire du vélo mais non une
bonne activité de kobe
sinon et je me suis mis à la couture
trèbes 2022 moi de me mettre à l'actif
des gestes ou d'écouteurs et je sais pas
si je suis bonne mais c'est l'état
d'esprit que je peux pas croire sinon
mais jamal c'est quoi que du coup qu'est
ce qui est tu fais et un belgique au
mans parce que j'en rencontre avec
gilles duceppe beaucoup de boutons roule
et j'ai comme le pigeon mais sache les
machines à sous
saviez-vous c'est souvent une question
d'équipement
battus 2 tu te suit des cours d'économie
familiale non chypre est trop jeune pour
se bousculent dans la rue
ouais ouais on est des cours d'économie
familiale puis les souvenirs que j'ai de
ce son
comme rien j'ai pris pis j'ai amené avec
moi le banc dans la suite des choses le
fait pas pour toi non mais les deux sont
gérés cousue j'avais connu des bigoudis
pour mettre sur mon on retrouve heures
de mon sort
ces deux gros des lucky balancer comme
ce cas le char ou lil wayne fallait
faire un toutou mercier mythe tout à
fait des démos j'avais une licorne qui
je me souviens de qu'on a fait de la
croustade aux pommes ce je m'en souviens
je me souviens que la prof à nice un
père de son nom on a salu way avec salut
on avait dit toi quand tu cuisines
laisse pas le temps de manger en cuisine
en fac pas le droit de manger dans le
copier un goût de sa fin thiam avait
poignée à prendre un petit bout des cas
sanaa depuis m avait chicane est bien
mais j'avais plus droit de cuisine et
m'avait à six pilotes est ce mon côté
mais moi j'ai fait ma mémoire n'est
jamais eu et je me suis toujours dit je
me suis tout cas sony pourquoi il avait
en lui parce que je trouve ça tellement
essentiel petit aubin un endroit
les actions non mais bon la cuisine
thomas couderc taux est absente de m'en
faire sa comptabilité
il faut qu'ils soient reçus je sais le
saas est le même qui revient souvent
deux fois combien de fois est ce qu'il
me suis servi de tagore dans ma vie mais
ton combien de fois est ce que je sais
ce que je suis devant mettons un rapport
de taxe puisque je me dis
j'ai aucune car les idées de qu'est ce
qui va ou pire des termes là dedans
quand on dirait que ça pourrait du
chinois pipi je vais enfin le gel cdm
athletissima l'apprendre à les appliquer
aux perdants mais oui la machine est
perdante amatrices du système scolaire
non non et non
ok il ya beaucoup de lacunes mais tu
sais quand on entend par contre parce
que c'est pas quelque chose je sais pas
si j'ai jamais entendu parler ton
parcours ce qu'on en fait
en fait et new build est tellement le
fils me dit tu es mieux me dire que tu
as fait un doctorat en sciences ou de
rendez compte que c'était parce que moi
je le sais mouche chez les bleus je sais
que tu vas et hq mais c'est pas grave
raconte torpiller mais obama vous je
suis ce qu'on appelle communément est en
fait j'étais une petite crise est mis
je tenais pas en place non plus fait que
le système scolaire et comme comme il
l'est parce que sais je sais que
maintenant les écoles j'allais à l'école
régulière et était vraiment pas un
système qui collait avec ma personnalité
d'enfants et d'adolescents sécu mots
parce que là à cinq écoles secondaires
en 400 qui j'ai arrêté j'ai doublé mon
salaire 3 qui j'ai fini aux adultes on
may 11 qui était vraiment plus adapté
pour moi d'ailleurs à 13 ans
l'écho régulière et comme ces six même
pas légal
et comme je crois en toi je sais que tu
vas réussir comme le doute je l'avais vu
leurs deux fois dans ma vie mais mais
coincée qui finalement est destiné aux
adultes en travaillant le marché sur le
marché de pâques et bat son plein puis
j'ai fini formation à distance a suffi
dans le fond ce site va pas du tout à
l'école de jus des cahiers islam ce qui
convenait le mieux percevoir ce qui est
appris que légitime selon lui allié à
l'ithq pharmacie et une attestation
d'études collégiales en cuisine de trois
ans mon parcours scolaire
mais c'est vraiment la preuve que
justement le système scolaire
et pas daté pour tout le monde c'est
parce que tous manifestement tu es
quelqu'un qui réussit dans la vie je
voudrais c'est pas parce que tu étais
pas capable d'accomplir des choses ou de
faire de quoi là mais l'école était pas
un bon fait pour toi a dit le témoin
mettant au contraire l'école de charette
outaouais futé et puis j'avais des
bonnes notes saleh belge karen vers tir
par coup par coup normal j'ai pris monde
autour de moi petit moi je fais de la
musique en plus puis surtout à musique
témoin mettons donc ses parents
moi j'ai étudié à dents puis ça m'a
vraiment servi puis parce que j'arrêtais
quelqu'un qui a été folle autodidacte
qu'il faut être capable de le faire par
moi-même
il y en a d'autres que de moi qui sont
tellement bons que les autres c'est
juste naturel ou c'est juste comme lio
l'école t'es pas bon fit mais ils y ont
appris piste harvey norman ce tabou mais
c'est normal vu des décors sur tapuai eu
un parcours scolaire régulier un peu
comme si tu étais comme ceux de
s'arrêter à dire t'es pas dans le moule
fait que dans le fond avec une grosse
demi foule de pression est de pavot fini
mon secondaire d'une façon normale comme
juge et je pense que je pense que le
problème il vient vraiment éviter années
le système d'éducation faut faut que tu
ailles dessin certains stands or pour
être tué parce qu'il ya tellement
tellement john pitié doivent quand même
une base à apprendre mais j'ai
l'impression que le problème vient
vraiment dans la stigmatisation des gens
pour qui c'est pas fait pour eux c'est
moi mettons pour prendre mon exemple moi
si c'était pas du support puis la raison
principale cocheril je sais pourquoi je
suis allé en sport études au secondaire
que je taleo au cégep en sport-études
aussi paix à l'université pour manger
pour le rouge et or si c'était pas du
support
souvent je le disais à mes parents et
moi je détestais me lever le matin pour
aller à l'école
souvent je suis à mes parents moi je moi
je vais faire un dp en boulangerie peas
qui je dois être content de se joindre
vraiment heureux faire ce jeu c'est même
pas un joker
souvent phi phi finalement t'es juste
parce que j'avais le sport j'ai persisté
dans ce mais je pense que le problème
vient vraiment de l'ajustement de la
deûle espèce d'idée de la connotation
négative qui vient avec
avec les gens qu'ils font est moi c'est
vraiment pas pour moi puis c'est pas la
façon avec laquelle je veux apprendre
puis je me forme et s'il ya un million
de façon de se former team est on
aujourd'hui si tu veux commencer la
couture c'est pour lui d'aller faire un
cours en couture le format exact
non mais je dirais surtout faut qu'il y
ait une place pour ce genre mais je
pense que les dsp justement ce n est une
bonne place pour pour ces gens là qui
allait faire quelque chose d'appliquer
vraiment rapidement travailler là dedans
mais si c'est exact c'est pas parce
qu'on n'est pas finalement mais comme on
se répète mais pas parce qu'on est
pauvre pas sans un certain moule qu'on
est con des bons à rien faire
mais toi comme moi mettons et j'ai
l'oubli qui heureusement que j'ai fait
ma thèse de tongres et jal parce que mon
cours de cuisine est tellement tellement
j'avais genre je pense surtout à deux
mains nues et voit vraiment que c'est
pas une question de problèmes
d'apprentissage problème d'intérêt je
dois apprendre les choses à apprendre
par coeur des choses qui m'intéressent
pas ce genre gros problème et à prendre
les affaires de dates ou pas mais alors
pas du tout spécial à partir des picards
étaient alités hqv excuse parce que
quand tu es rentré sur martin le marché
du travail est en restauration ou mais
c'est quelque chose que tu avais
toujours intéressé ou est en fuite
j'ai arrêté de travailler restauration
l'anip aussi ça fait un an maintenant si
j'ai fait dix ans respiration au tout
dans les cuisines sur le plancher mais m
sur le plancher jamais
ava ient en cuisine et l'inflation comme
south et sauf que ti je connais très
bien l'ambiance de la restauration ils
tous ok quand j'allais perdre mon
courage du cpo en pensant travailler
dans une cuisine et savent jamais jamais
jamais été réunies
il faut être vraiment
amazon pour l'autre est intense et 6 3
qui comme apple a remis moi parce que
tous des moins bonnes conditions
c'est vraiment intense mode suspecte à
ce qu'ils font mais moi ça m'a jamais
intéressé par ce que je vais faire je
n'ai pas peur du tout c'est mon but
commercial
c'est ce qui m'intéressait et tous et
nous voici nous y voilà
c'est drôle que tu parles d'armé pour
comparer la cuisine parce qu'on a reçues
de bleu bob le chef le podcast élèves
et oui mais veilleux pie ix a utilisé la
même analogie le séquestre s'est
confirmée au grade qui font que tu
respectes supérieur pinailler et papa de
personnes pillent eh oui c'est toutes
les modes de vie autant la restauration
on n'entend parler que tu sais ce que je
t'assure partait ça boit ça prend la
drogue se 6 étoiles à ton expérience des
tentes au milieu c'est comme ça tu
exagérée ou c'est vraiment demain dépend
du resto ou du travail accompli et tu
m'étonnes j'ai trahi au pied de cochon à
montréal et qui voudrait passer un job
qui est extrêmement difficile parce que
c'est un resto avec d'histoire d'or
extrêmement élevé donc des métros et je
faisais des daurades de hockey je
faisais des deux ans a reculé à 2 heures
du matin tous les jours
quatre jours par semaine plusieurs à
l'école plus je faisais du tout et que
je vais poster votre fessier comme mode
de vie et un petit oui c'est sûr qu'on
boit de l'alcool à côté parce que ce
service est souvent ils vont se faire
beau fait que trois morts a été clair
sur le forum
une tâche d'être souligné je suppose
comme acheter mbao
on va te saouler est absurbe et
qu'est-ce qui a affaire à deux heures du
matin après les bords vers un grand jour
mais qui a été constamment et sous les
flashes de l'alcool et puis c'est sûr
que certains députés size as a service
et paas et invested brosse de colle ici
depuis ce temps je me suis réveillé dans
la poêle puis diffusée jusqu'en mai mais
jessica mettant en cuisine ça va être
comme c'est tellement difficile
travailler dans une cuisine pour y
fonder 14-16 horreur des fois c'est même
un effet qu'est-ce qui est plus qu un
karting mais qu'un cash closets j'ai
travaillé vraiment pas longtemps le
moins d'un an a cage aux sports dans
cuisine le piquant josé c'était le
meilleur but parce qu il rendu vraiment
tort des dégâts la cité couvert de sueur
plaindre de notre gérant de cuisine y
arriver avec un pichet de bière en
arrière il mettait le pichet de bière
second tour lequel je dirais de ce
contraste avec le dernier client était
sorti ou qui l'accusait n'était fermée
dans le fond le fait que le cuisinier
qui était sa ligne il mettait la radio
puis on écoutait du metallica puis on
close et la cuisine bien devant la
biogue c'était comment enfin et c'est ça
me rappelle vraiment beaucoup en fait
l'espèce de feeling après un effort
physique soutenu mettons une course
quand je vais courir puis je reviens
après c'est comme accès l'espèce de
calme après la tempête
j'ai juste dit que quand je la musique
et aux mains des gouttes cph tourné deux
fois le tipi juste la fin de soirée
tickets c'est moi moi ma bague est finie
pied
les serveurs prennent guère de sens qui
est comme on est passé à travers d'une
autre soit répété ses gammes à chaque
fois c'était une petite guerre qui on
travaille
demain commence ce qui est à faire d une
fois mais c'est sûr que oui là quand
j'avais 18 ans et 2 qui s'est baptisé le
était situé à côté de la saq express et
qu'il ne s'accuse ouvert jusqu'à 22h
mais je pense là pour de vrai
aujourd'hui comme ça n'a pas de bon sens
que représente ce pas votre temps et on
a les ch'tis par une bouteille de rhum
ou deux puis on avait de machine à tubes
mascaret au bol qui est au fait des
shooteurs des hommes et des idées cela
pendant shift devant les kia au bord
11 02 nique quand même un show à peine
chiffres qui ont fait défaut c'est
quelque chose qu'on appelle la tournée
des bières importées par les chips book
search a toujours quelque chose de
rapide mais qu'à composer un sommet du
box des gens tout les fûts on les
pensait alors on se met une guenon
mettais trop opaque de da et au talent
et à la vieille garde
le valais qu'ils comprennent et je
comprends même pas qu'on va qu'on
faisait ce genre il était temps coucou
ce qui fait la force et que mes méthodes
les gérants des jeux dans le coup non
wen est bien calé j'ai rappelé palmer
les âges et jean louis becker comme
gérald pelleau fallait qu'on soit
liquidée par mail à la fin si on faisait
ce côté bord sont captés ce les os
serveur y retourner côté salle à manger
qui est complètement lâché avec son
plateau avec des nuggets en forme
d'animaux le pic
comment ça commence à le commencer le
youtube games pour toi qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui a fait maintenant que tu
es un moment marquant au studio créé
maquille ya quelque chose là et on fait
quand j'ai commencé un peu plus que ça
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un du nom de jean
nadeau un bon un bonjour puis moi je la
connaissais par exemple qui me
connaissait rien du game on est en
quelle année le s et yes is a man lisant
on a commencé et ben ils ont lavé et 50
mille abonnés sur youtube cas qu'on
s'est rencontrés c'est ce que pour moi
c'est à dire fuck métiers autres que je
connaissais bien le dire ou bien tout
seul à la classique et you tube you
there qui est qu'au début ok ça s'arrête
le mali si ben on est devenus on est
devenu vraiment ali puis elle a la tête
dans ce sens le avec
série heroes et semant son époque le
fait que j'ai bâtie comme barnes n'a pas
de quartier ou beurs faut juste du
commis le double concert m'a fait me
suis adapté mettons rapidement à leur
univers et les réseaux sociaux
non non on y voit qui est salement moi
je moi je finissais mon bêtement je
commençais à le cacher comme dans
quelques mois quand j'ai encore présents
terry m'a dit pourquoi tu fais par
youtube de bouffe télécom
monté jusqu'à l'épaule et l'a jamais une
idée maintenant ça va hein as après midi
je dessine même et mon pied tout cas ne
sait vraiment à l'oeuvre ici je
m'attendais pas à ça va être ma carrière
jusqu'à cinq ans de le faire jalali que
j'apprenais des truc c'est que je me dis
d'un crime je pourrais genre montre que
des trucs sur le web et j'ai commencé
facture et ma chaîne youtube n'était pas
exacte aujourd'hui mais c'est bourré de
bonnes volontés belles choses
apparaissent assez c'est ce qui paraît
le plus
ouais mais évidemment ça a évolué et
puis ma mère et mon métier juin puis
juste à mal s'était permis de carrément
l'aja reste à l'instant pour faire juste
mais na waie et ça m'a pris longtemps
avant d'écrire cela reste assez simple
c'est sûr au début cela ma première
année où j'ai eu dix mille abonnés je
faisais pas le boulanger mas 2 mai
en fait c'est parce que j'aime c'est la
restauration plus j'ai quelque chose que
j'adore fait qu à la fin c'est un peu de
gens vont être vraiment stable qui
j'aime vraiment ça la réformation fait
que ça me tente pas de mama next est
rendue ingérable eux j'étais plus
capable de gérer mon horreur au resto
parce que je l'avais bégaye
le fait que ça marchait plus fait qu
aucune piste
tant mieux c'est quand même le grand
show wey kaw pileux depuis le
confinement au dépô t cha blé voir que
la cadence avait un peu ralenti c'est
juste l'impression ou non mais en fait
elle avait ralenti pour avancer ok
maintenant
en 2009 pile je suis encore en train de
remonter la pente et de tout ceux et
celles prises et mentalement de revenir
à quai ce que c'était avant jeu j'essaie
de me mettre trop de pression sur les
vidéos youtube parce que je m'en mettait
énormément je m'en mets encore mais
c'est de plus relax ce soutien pendant
le confinement moi je travaille avec
avec ma couverture et qui s'appelle
rebecca trambly llc one pourrait pour le
piano
pis elle est encore fumants aussi de son
bord et qu'on ne peut faire des vidéos
mais le futur commentaires des comptines
et un peu et on s'est parlé peut-être la
semaine prochaine coupe puis s'était pas
à l'aise d'en parler par exemple mais
mais mais je trouve ça intéressant je
pense pas il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui est qu'ils vont se reconnaître dans
un stress lié au travail comment ça tu
est apparue initialement sur notre le
commun ce qui te vu des signes ou à ce
que te fait ok non lieu est quelque
chose dans mois et quelque chose dans la
façon avec laquelle j'aborde ce que
j'aimais faire qui l'homme et
différentes salles et qui vrillent
aimant graduelle pour ce qui est sa
fille vraiment longtemps avant de
comprendre que ce qui se passait et ne
s'arrête pas tombé dessus comme je pense
pas que ça tombe sur personne juste
d'une chute non plus effectué au début
c'est les petits trucs quand même et
j'ai arrêté de faire des choses que je
fais avant lui comme le répétait je peux
de prendre un moment pour moi j'ai
arrêté de m'entraîner la magnifie
j'espère que j'arrêtais de la manche à
la fois que je ne peux faire un monde
parce que tout ce que je faisais c'était
travail et qui se fait arriver comme je
vous ai remettons mélanie passé j'ai
même pas fait et ma famille tous genres
y rit parce que j'étais en train de
faire mais jerry moyes youtube joliment
installe j'avais 3 contre eupen ninja
qui est en train de faire plus il
fallait que je fasse toutes les photos
pour mon livre ou complets jusqu'à dix
journées à peu près de douze heures
pendant un mois et 5 jours par semaine
texter complètement cinglé
qui
j'ai juste arrêté de toute autre
activité que travailler
j'ai tout arrêté avec le hamman et j'ai
commencé à voir des signes de stress
énorme physique fait que dit que je
m'assoyais si je me batte encore avec se
dit que je m'assoie devant mon ordi pour
commencer à travailler sur un montage de
mon cerveau hymne des tigres était
membre a right que le ch est rendue que
ça me semble piquer un petit y est j'ai
checké qui est âgée et un autre chez
keops mais même ma manche aurait déjà
aux kings série des diplômes il pas bien
il épie crise montpellier que celle ci
n'est pas comme si je suis poli je
faisais une tâche et le troc aux pieds
je mets ma retraite mais c'est juste mon
corps qui était juste comme aura tout vu
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui clochait
qui sait sur ma relation de coucy en a
pris une austin daye vaste fait que tout
allait pas bien que je vous ai même si
je suis allé voir mon médecin parce que
je commence à vos pensées nouveau c'est
le rugby qui est mon médecin me
conseille de prendre son successeur
après plusieurs avec tam a pas juste
presque comme si elle a vraiment fait
attention et qui commence à prendre
depuis maintenant je prends vraiment du
mieux et c'est au jour le jour le comme
on dit un peu quétaine comme
l'expression et risquent entre six mois
bell ca/cause demander mieux comme au
petit coin une autre affaire le un autre
singh j'avais
pakol plus d'énergie que je suis la
personne avec plus d'énergie sauf love
king planète qui le jeu mais
reconnaissent eux mêmes que le che
jamais cru capable d'entreprendre un
projet d'acheter juste comme cela ça me
sentais comme mon dieu d'un choriste
demain et pour toujours et de l'énergie
aujourd'hui mais pas bien j'avais de moi
ils ne répondent pas un con mais
justement c'est drôle c'est pas drôle
mais tantôt j'écoutais le podcast que tu
as fait excellent cru tipi je pense que
c'est exactement dans cette période là
parce que tu disais bien passé je
faisais mon shooting pour info mon livre
d'anna puis de la mana qu est ce que tu
m'en parle effectivement que ça n'avait
pas de la dalle et si mathilde en juge
sans jus la part de quelqu'un ou
complètement au bout du rouleau mais
messi j'imagine qu'ils étaient bonnes à
à masquer un peu le débat pas comme tout
était calé
puis se tassait skate a réussi à
identifier certains certaines d'affaires
plus que d'autres qui participait à
cette espèce de de charge mentale les
affaires qui que tu juges est peut-être
poème c'est parce qu'il ya vraiment une
limite de trucs que tu peux faire
d'antan dans ta vie pis si beaucoup de
cette option au pourcentage de ces
choses là sont des trucs qui font chier
ou créer un quelque chose que tu aimes
pas nécessairement même si ça fait du
sens d'efforts pour x ou y raison s'il
ya un pourcentage des trucs que tu fais
au quotidien qu'il faut nécessairement
ce que tu ferais si tu avais le choix
sans pour saturer sert ici de comprendre
un petit peu qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui
avait amené là où ben c'est juste le
suit le surtravail tous ces mélanges de
travail parce que je me suis lancé many
qui aussi que s'il avait déjà et dans le
fond mais je me pose est là justement
que ça soit comme parfait justement que
ce soit que ça se démarque que ça soit
que je mets beaucoup de pression pige
mais énormément de travail dans un seul
vidéo et j'ai calculé ou quelque chose
comme ça nous prenait sans faire une
vidéo
je ne prends 91 puis c'est sûr qu'il ya
des trucs là bas que c'est pas mes
affaires préféré à faire tout le
processus de la vidéo mais une partie
que j'aime foule
j'écoute de gmail que j'aime si le
montage
j'aime vraiment ce sauf que ça me prend
tellement de teint
tellement dépendants des vidéos sur
lesquelles on a passé les 40 50 heures
de montage le sable ça le juste pas
khalife de bon sens n'ont vu que même
maintenant quand je pense que je pense à
faire une vidéo
j'ai comme le petit guide de stress de
mon corps qui me dit mon fait pas ce
parce que je me suis j'ai tellement mis
tout ce que j'avais rabbin pays comme
pieces of music sommes pas sûrs que je
veux tu recommences a à faire ce mais
pour ce que j'ai comme une relation
amour-haine avec le montage demain mais
comme à toutes les étapes de faire une
vie où je les aime mais c'est juste que
les montages à faire un truc et ça me
pèse métier c'est qui cette attention là
au montage clairement apparu le sédatif
dojo s'imagine pas sûr de l'avoir
maintenant laisser ça mais c'est aussi
se prend le même des raisons pourquoi
c'est pourquoi ça pogne autant pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que tu es et tu es truc
marche autant c'est parce que c'est
vraiment de la qualité des tirs après ça
c'est 10 rebonds mais qu'est-ce qui est
étiez 1 qu'est ce qui est essentiel
qu'est ce qu'il l'ait pas fait quelque
chose que tu serais prête à déléguer ou
jamais de les guérir cette tâche que
quelqu'un est tellement pensé à fond et
b qui l'a fait avec qui schumi vidéo est
là qu elle ne décroche et une grosse
partie
m ce qu'on filme énormément mais ton
parce que c'est la cuisine c'est comme
si peu comme juste toxicomane qui est qu
à camden les fautes et du major 1h
mettons que je dois réduire à peu près
15 minutes
mais si lunaire de stock complet que
c'est tous des haras qui pourrait servir
avec de faire le tri la date de décider
le pays
qu'est-ce que c'était une question aussi
de mettre ce que vous faites c'est une
business pitt se pose la question à qui
et comment qu'on peut arriver un aussi
bon résultat à moins de ressources moins
de temps et il ya sûrement des moyens de
dire qui est peut-être que c'est chez
paddy lowe fucking bien correct on est
celle de mon père de montage mais
peut-être des championnes des trucs que
tu peux faire que des pluies s'être fait
que ça va plus vite peut-être dit ok on
vous ramène plus brestois mais avare
pour shooter - pour avoir moins de roche
pour avoir gagner du temps après tout le
truc peut faire que 6 rbds il y était
aussi beau aussi bon mais tommy le
duster du tabac ces deux organismes pjj
et jj non même en pensée pour le
logiciel de montage on les utilise les
mains de la façon la plus efficiente
passé parce qu'ils trient ce qui lui
valut de perdre mon temps gâché ce
montage participe aux grandes façon et
de paris puis cet apport mai animation
parce que c'est comme un stratège
parodie puis 7
tu m'aimes encore le jeu tellement
mondiale que j'essaye tout le temps
dessus les animations au fait que ça ça
me prend un temps fou
et puis mes vidéos sont en fait foule
construite la majorité des gens savent
trop sur mais je fais tout le temps une
planification vidéo avant de fermer
vidéo c'est une arène de travail d'école
de gaz mans qui sait comme le titre est
ce que je veux pour le turn est un et
puis après seul un troquet ce que je
faisais pour les prunes des d'animation
pour qu'on prenne des chutes de choses
confirme animations et après ce lourd de
la vidéo évidemment la recette
j'ai testé le rester tout et j'ai écrit
j'ai apprécié on fait juste prendre les
choses comme comme son écrit mais si je
suis souvent fait que ces affaires le
jeu donne un exemple comme le la
prochaine de fax et au reste transparent
et que mal a besoin faut quand même
filmé toutes les étapes de toutes les
recettes parce que je suis pour
qu'est ce que je vous dis tu est
essentiel de laisser au montage
finalement je t'apprends rien mais c'est
kif kif octobre ces cas ci c'est
d'essayer pas du contenu de qualité a
été finalement aussi bon qu est ce que
tu feras tv mais que des équipes de 10
15 20 personnes oui c'est ça exagéré ses
dreads sept ans qu'on attend 6 1 mettons
que tu que je te dit infinie de
ressources devant toi quel est le
scénario au plus plus plus que quelques
tôles de ma team qu'est ce que ce serait
comme team n'ont pas nécessairement
comme steam mettons c'est quoi ton
scénario idéal pour dire qu'ils n'ont le
serai vraiment confortable de faire ce
dans le temps que ça prendrait mettons
mais c'est d'avoir un monteur
professionnels à qui tu fais 100%
confiance c'est tout il y bien parce que
ça s'peut cela existe-t-il
j'essaie méga j'ai essayé d'en trouver
et comme quelque chose qui est vraiment
inquiet pour moi d'une certaine façon
parce que j'ai évidemment comme hostile
et qu'il faudrait que la personne comme
respecter le mandat fixé comme un
peintre faty qui toutes les gens avec
qui j'ai essayé de faire des tests pour
voir si et je pourrai délégué montage
on y monte d'une façon il était très bon
mais il monte une façon classique du
tout c'est à dire des espèces de
dénouement du mal constamment si des
gens de mime et à droite à gauche
et très face piste mais comme un petit
peu trop pour la cuisine
qu'est que ça
sa coulpe au pis ça parle serait jamais
genre je mettrai sur lui donc il montré
comme le phoque
ce gaulliste c'est ça la face et que les
mots sont tellement habitués à ton style
davantage qu'elle est il connaît
tellement bien qu'ils vont prendre ça
rend compte mais en même temps mais
j'aimerais tellement seul e si vous
saviez comment j'aimerais ça pour
trouver quelqu'un
à la limite là à la limite écoles kipp
registre les animations ça serait une
femme parce que je pense vraiment être
fou qui est une professionnelle bombe
institut du coup de sabre à envoyer
votre votre portfolio faveur fév-1er
mars et quoi c'est un site web wasquehal
mettons moi j'ai une photo que je veux
exister puisque le tutu peut voir toutes
les personnes qui offrent leurs services
dédiés oui tu vois un meeting avec des
étoiles le nombre de rating puis
maintenant on te plusieurs paliers
maintenant cinq pièces par photo 31,5 en
tête jusqu'à mettons 10000 pièces par
photo ses pilotes le tu peux faire des
tu peux l'envoyer tu en vois le truc qui
si c'est bon c'est bon c'est pas bon ben
on va payer ce type pour que ce soit pas
bon mais ça revient quand même type qui
sait qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
nous on a beaucoup portfolio différent
tu peux le faire pour des vidéos fait
calmes et ont tari victoire ' tu dis
voici le rush qui fait mois pour 30
pièces la meilleure chose que tu peux
faire le petit cadenas tu vas tomber sur
quelque chose qui fait crise ça me
ressemble non bâti parce que dans sûr
que dans la masse il y en a l'autre
question que j'avais sous jacente à
soupe c'était pas une plogue pour fiber
le jeune tchèque suède
mais l'autre question que j'avais c'est
ce que tu penses que
d'un tout ce
puis moi je sais que c'est mon coeur les
moments parce que tu le plus stressé
c'est souvent parce que j'ai de la
misère avec le laisser aller
est ce que tu penses que ceci est un
problème que tu aimes
c'est comme quand tu passe notre vie
donnez moi tes qualités défauts petit 10
h ou perfectionner à rabat mais si mais
toi c'est ce qu'on voulait je suis
absolument y capable de faire les choses
à moitié
ça me choque pas je suis pas
physiquement capable je vais juste pour
arrêter ce soir exactement comme joueur
puis je me mets la pression qui je peux
pour ça aussi que j'ai de la misère à
déléguer il parce que ça me tente pas de
taper ça fait de personnes qui jouent de
tout le monde est bon en question qui
j'ai moi j'ai mon idée fixe
c'est du style que tibet qui mettons ça
fait trois ans qu'on travaille ensemble
pour le tout mais quand tu connais et
avec qui elle aurait la cei tout comme
ans que je suis mais j'ai évolué avec
elle alors comment alors au fur et à
mesure mais tant que je le promets je
prépare bien plus de contenu je pourrais
bravo qu'une vie puisse une option de
dirk et moi je
je veux travailler 40 heures semaine
puis dati depuis j'en ferai pas plus
puis ça prendra le temps que ça prendra
faire une vidéo où ben c'est pas une
option face à
en vrai que le choc jusqu'au mans
vacances vous dis que j'aurais pu faire
comme maire
king
et ouais oui absolument le rabais
mais tend habituellement cachée des
vidéos du moment où je me lève je suis
comme il ya 12 heures à la fin de ma
journée
dans le podcast jacques tits direct des
photos montées jusqu'à midi la gentille
couche est pas un c'est un mandat
jusqu'à midi la main 6 le feu mais j'ai
tout fait j'ai beau me disent souvent
lemay mettant à manille je fais un bisou
avec est moléculaire qui lui faisait une
vidéo sur sa chaîne
moi je sache et son machin qui les duos
et tester un horaire moi je me mets
jamais d'horaires non ça va pas avec moi
lorsque lui mettons ya un nombre de
vidéos tu sors pas commis et que les
médias qui fête mercredi pour avoir la
vidéo
là on est un phoque
mais fallait quand même que je suis les
cfd au fait que j'ai monté jusqu'à midi
le lendemain j'en avais commencé à 23
ça c'est ça aïe ouille
puis pour l'avoir fait pour finir de la
voir devenir de leforest en fait écrire
un livre de recettes c'est c'est du toc
aussi fait que c'est sûr que celle pesé
un peu dans ton dans ton schéma de
charge mentale parce que tu penses tout
le temps ce petit mais dont têtu
est ce qu'au final l'expérience
d'écriture genève a été plus a été
positif j'imagine m
chez eux comme chez exactement ça
représente mais on skie vi est bonne
tout le temps même si mme et on est
super content du résultat final le
processus pour se rendre là dans un t on
s'entend tu étais pas en train de
décrire
n'est pas en train d'écrire un roman de
l'auteur n'était pas en train d'écrire
le plongeur était en train de faire
quelque chose que tu sais qui va être
d'une certaine façon de la consommation
impulsive de gens qui achètent tout les
livres de recettes fait que tu sais
qu'il ya quand même des deadline à
fournir parce que twain et d'histoire
qui travaille avec toi mais que toute
cette pression la came as tu l'as vécu
des débats sur un pote pour lutter m
d'hamar d'oppression mais des petites
choses sur lesquelles je travaille et
c'est pas moi je peux dire que mon lit
plat le plus fort et même plus paiement
que mon chat puis les petits phoques qui
ont eu avec les deadlines ce que j'ai
rencontré la maison d'édition je leur ai
dit je vais parler mon projet je leur ai
montré l'escale du livre c'est chez qui
c'est les éditions de l'homme qui était
super intéressé par le projet qui était
comme hakim on te revient soupire avec
un contrôle c'est toi qui est approché
avec moi avec mon avec mon agent que si
vous avez paceman intéresser des clubs
un mois pas de moi france pour une
transe pourtant de nouvelles david les
jeux lance ce l'équipe est super équipe
et parce qu'il venait de lancer genre ou
olive est vraiment gros lift et qui
avait comme une bille et lancement faire
il m'avait dit faut absolument surtout
son livre en septembre parce que c'est
comme ma rentrée des classes se passe
fait que comme catherine rose
illégalement pendant lesquelles les
autres il devait penser que tout ce
travail était fort mais n'ont aussi
parce que moi je dis pas de nouvel
effectif comme mais au pire je vais
aborder une maison d'édition plon faire
les choses différemment et finalement
ils reviennent comme je sais peut-être
cinq mois plus tard les deux jeunes
allemands et ils reviennent me sens
commun qui partait au nom de tous pour
toi de 200 commerçants laisse quand même
fait sortir pour cet homme blond et à
quel moment on y était et j'ai si peu le
fric je regarde mac do you to pas ce que
j'espère c'est que youtube est immonde
et j'ai sauté au tour où je m'entraînais
tous les jours pendant un mois mais
ouais c'est que et j'avais comme je
parle j'avais trois mois pour être
humain perso si possible parce que
chaque pack tenir cet attentat il faut
que l'écrivent qu'il va aborder crise et
à la pression tu achètes les ingrédients
les puis ce n'est pas gentil pour
vraiment prendre le filet fait une fois
deux fois trois fois
quoi qu'il en soit parfait le faux qu'il
a rédigé des paris pourquoi le dr dexma
si c'est juste pour une réussite
dans mon livre j'en ai aussi
complètement mogul fait que j'ai fait ça
pendant pendant trois mois non-stop loge
tous les jours dieu bénisse ma mère et
moi puis après ce et il fallut faire la
rédaction à 6 de six points de base à 6
sur mon tabouret
avec mon ordi toutes mes feuilles de
papier chiffonné prennent des notes
puis je me sens si pendant deux jours
bat abattent les seules fois que je me
suis levé ces deux jours le temps pour
m'entraîner tout ce que je dirai juste
écrire exec vérifier qu'il faut être
foule attentive parce que tu le pot
chier un ingrédient il mesure à une
cuillère à soupe une thérapie lorsque
ces pièces et puis après ça j'ai dormi
pendant une journée complète
c'est c'est débile puis toi en plus
c'est nous émettons avec vega n'est pas
plate ont fait en faire une maison
d'édition qui pratique aux pratiques
qu'ils auront des chefs in house puis
qui ont des rédacteurs a lui aussi fait
nouveau dans le fond on arrive avec la
recette on la faisait ici puis là on
l'envoyait plus haut il y avait des
chefs qui dit que de leur équipe qui
s'assuraient que la recette mettons y
avait toutes les quantités étaient
exactes tout était parfait pour le truc
c'est son sens tant d'autres cette
partie de la job
maintenant moi ça a été compliqué puis
disent ils écrire les lignes de recettes
puis on n'avait pas cette partie en fait
que j'imagine même pas comme un singe ou
est pesant dans un temps aussi restreint
que trois ou quatre mois pour écrire sur
le site débile mais si vraiment il ya
l'exécuteur expérience mais
mais tend maintenant les photos des
recettes à ce que c'est c'est toi qui se
cuisiner pour comprendre la photo à qui
est fait est fait le gip a pris les
photos ils fatiguent pas photographe
packing d'accès et puis j'étais tombé
d'enfants on a fait deux shoots on a
fait un show chez mon agent qui sont
comme les laits ou tu vois plus comme on
n'a pas tout est en studio de c'est ce
qui a été pris à moi et qui comme je
veux que chaque photo soit comme théo
comme qui se passe quelque chose dans
chaque photo que tu puisses comme pensée
chico le piquer ma maison d'édition
était comme pense poxy réalise genre je
pense qu'on va pouvoir le faire jeter
comme chaque mauvais état dans le fait
qu'ils trouvent la marque et couteaux
sont je suis vraiment vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment faire des photos mais
oui c'est mon cas amélie vraiment nos
félicitations à eux tu étais tu es tu
satisfait de la réception ça tu sais
c'est une impasse et oui mais dans le
fond est le seul chiffre que j'ai ici
que on en a rien à mes parents l'avaient
en effet mis dix mille fait que je suis
juste content de vendre plus que dix
mille mais si c'est vraiment difficile à
rodez schaeffler les maisons d'édition
fait q qu'est ce qu'on en a vendu plus
qu'utile
mais c'est beaucoup le cinéma beaucoup
de bien au québec aux énoncés beaucoup
si non je suis bien content mais qui
pour des billets comme jp pêche tue pas
fait de livres pour mr maîtrise le
stepway épisode est
m c'est sûr mais je suis vraiment
contente quitter tout le monde qu'ils
l'ont eu
maudite et m'envoyer sur install genre
des recettes à venir il y avait fait
seul ça remplit moteur de bonheur de
voir mes recettes utilisant ont fait le
reste
passe éclair qui l'a maintenant mettre
maintenant
ski qu'est ce qui s'en vient pour toi
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui est qu'est ce
que tu vois dans ton futur court moyen
long et mes cours et causse nasri serait
ma santé mentale parce qu'il faut
vraiment que je sois formation de
peumerit épuisé parce que j'ai trouvé
mon énergie
ce serait dommage ma tendance à ce qui
est offert de la fin j'essaye de prendre
du temps pour moi les rallyes toujours
sauf québec est enviée c'est que j'ai
deux ans que je travaille sur une
compagnie du joug est 100% fait à
montréal des années par nous y produit
qui on est exposé j'ai commencé les le
photoshoot avant le 1er mai c'est si
beau match qui pourrait survenir dans
les prochains temps le avec le
développement et santé commence et je
vais pour un mur partir là dessus mais
tu vois gens parlent peut s'investir un
peu comme le sait si je peux je peux
encore complètement du revenu ouais
étudiés
parce que je disais tu crois que ça a
commencé à aller moins vite
marcel est moins bien que comme coupés
dans des choses essentielles de service
qui s'affairent à manger tout ce temps
traîner pilote c'est l'homme a tenté par
l'ex antidépresseurs et et c'est une des
solutions pour recommencer à aller mieux
mais c'est quoi les autres choses que de
réintégrer à ta vie mettant la porte de
secours trouver un équilibre est sûr que
je pense que chaque personne qui sait
juste qu'on me le dise jusqu'au bout
pour que tu puisses recommencé à vivre
normalement parce que j'étais juste
incapable de changer parce que je t'ai
je pouvais même plus me dire même si
dans la pêche c'est comme si je reprends
mes bonnes habitudes puisque c'est
impossible c'est pas faisable mais notre
prétention pratiquement permis de
reprendre les bonnes habitudes cd de
pommier vraiment mon plus gros problème
en fait c'est mon sommeil le métier des
territoires de dépôt mellouli a toujours
l'appui et de recommencer à
par le ménage fait mon lavage et à
tisser c'est une des choses que j'avais
comme
les frac c'est une petite montagne
référent du corps et avec eux
quand même vraiment pas c'est moi mais
tu vois quand je commence à parler plus
de travail
le lagon revient rapidement - ben pâton
temps je vais ici a pas d'urgence
price n'y a pas d'urgence membres et y
compris le contenu c'est connu pour des
gens qu'il ya quand même quelque chose
pour contenir
dijon mais soyez là quand je reviens je
comprends mais c'est ce genre
oui outils ou jacky mège compagnie s
quel s quelque 10 km arrive à un bon
moment où ça ou ça te fait chier
mais comme tu es certainement pas la
seule le tiki était au bout du rouleau
qui un arrêt forcé sakho fait écrire
maquillage elle en avait besoin et ce
n'était pas la seule dans cette
situation le t on sont déboutés on est
beaucoup le à ces valoriser aussi le
surmenage piles et elle m'a tellement
tellement valoriser tout simplement dit
mettons
mais comme il met en valeur l avenir
avec comme merci aux 10 onces et autres
que tu sois capable de faire tout leur
possible et que ses hôtes mai
c'est juste pour saint martin saint pie
- je ne me mettais us pride a pas dormir
puis à à travailler constamment tpiy a
justement le faire dès 16 heures de
montage lui c'est comme élections mais
ça fait un temps parfaite rattrape seppi
vous savez j'ai déjà été le gars qui se
vendent des trois chorales et que les
petites vannes speed su sauter ça
t'amène chômage s'est tue pas mais la
valorisation pis ça fait son travail
mais se rend compte que le bull s'est
passée la finalité cette petite croix et
je me croyais au main event et bleu n'a
pas vraiment eu de l'épuisement
mais non
c'est off c'est une balance qui est
difficile à gérer vraiment qui c'est
pour qu'il faut que tu le réalisateur
mais au moins c'est d'être conscient des
dangers de turf est d'être capable de
de se garder des périodes où est ce que
j'écoute est justement un podcast qui
s'appelle un journal d'un entrepreneur
puis le gosse et il s'appelle julien à
oignies a fait des suppléments de
nutrition il parlait lui en ai eu des
grosses crises de panique dans le temps
aussi sa business a levé vraiment parce
qu'il était toujours son seul art qui a
mené le jeu suit la réalisation de qom
ok ce serait de bon sur l'air de travail
puis de 9 à 5
il va est ouvert mais sinon il va être
fermé
puis ce c'est mon autre celle là mon
cellulaire de social qui lui sera ouvert
tout le temps pour quand les gens
veulent me parler mais mes amis puis les
gens comme ce puits que tout le reste du
temps qu'à mon salaire de jobs et pau
vers je suis pas dans cette folle je pas
dans ce monde s'est tu le mets sur moi
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment vraiment autres
parce que j'ai commencé à essayer de
l'appliquer tedom tu sais le pour le
studio lethielleux fois en onze textes
est comme un dimanche soir planer amener
ses copains qui l'ont tué qu'on va
essayer de recadrer ça dans les heures
ouvrables pour pas qu'on soit rendue
parce que le faire une fois on sent qu'à
lister mais sega n'a menacé comme acquis
non s'est rendu tout le temps tu
hypnotique tu réponds pas quelqu'un qui
a quitté cria à 9h05 t5 retarde le truc
mais même où je les remarquer justement
qui est tout de suite chez ce type idées
fausses sur je t'écris en un soir
quelque chose puis tu me répondre la
même si ben correct si c'est vraiment un
répit
c'est moi je reçois des massages
plusieurs sens pau la nécessité et
l'urgence absolue à moins que ça soit
une urgence de répondu suite même si je
sais que l'urgence
ses portes et ses collègues de répondre
le lendemain en voici le message est la
personne qui est que ce texte que
tu vois pas tout le temps être là à là
il répond dans la seconde t'habitues les
gens à se il voit tout le temps de
texter ya sept ans d'enquêté répondants
secondes
ça c'est la technique donne mes amis de
dating et 10,4 comment sa dette une
feuille le même si tu vois quatre
qu'assad était quelqu'un même si tu vois
le texto arrivé au moment où est ce qui
arrive là réponse pas du tout parce que
si tu y répond de suite à votre
s'attendre à ce que tu répondes tout de
suite tout le temps quand tu le feras
pas un lavage fourchette et laisse la
languir pendant bon 12h le fan mais je
viens voir post bac enfants de 12 ans et
les cas ça se passe pas présenté par an
mais je trouve ça quand même pas perdre
et rêveront t on pas rock à construire
puis puis au plus long terme
sinon pour toi
j'aime pas ça trop seront projetés ça
sert à rien si ce n'est des objectifs de
celle ci par là qu'est ce qui va se
passer
j'aime vraiment mieux y aller avec
qu'est ce qui se passe si j'estime
mettons que je veux pas aux jours fériés
tout comme possible et comment es
possible mais ils y arrivent tous les
trucs dans vie s'autorise occasion
l'institut sim est honteux qu un plan à
long terme
j'ai senti le coup peu de choses qui
m'ont dit que tu aurais pu faire tu
montes arrivé comme par surprise sauf
être pas à côté parce que c'est dire non
mais dans deux ans je m'étais dit que
j'allais partir ma compagne de toufik si
je pense que j'aurais pu le tapis le
fait que maintenant j'ai même 36 au jour
le jour
titouan copropriété d'un duplex oui il
du monde dit l'ex bibi mais ce cette
aventure nous parce que c'est quand même
7,8 et stressant de la job du loup c'est
aussi satisfait ça devait être bouclé et
rien de plus logique et de parfaire un
jeu complet
on le sait commencé les rennais ya rien
de plus ce mode python vote toujours
vraiment bien
ces descentes non non ça c'est le
bestiau rien de mieux que la tension qui
est au travail pour une relation de
copieurs iain nuque ce genre de question
que je pose dans pas de casque je sais
déjà la réponse c'est en avril ali
pacifique spectacle en même temps que
mon livre d'art latine et la tactique
est belle et je suis avec mon copain
dans des puits
mais a vécu mais leur 4 4 5 mois qui
sait on encore le décollage ensemble on
l'a encore leader en somme mais consent
pas conçu par oublier l'enfer c'était
quelqu'un me dit tu vas voir quelque
chose je m'attends à ce qu'il fasse le
problème quand une maison avec quelques
tickets abe sneijder vient de travailler
mais c'est normal
le boulgou asti de se remettre et
dominique et new york times en citant
pau et que ça qui est la discorde
je dis c'est pas si grave sur un couple
c'est souvent le cd j'oubliais mes amis
qui fait de l'immobilier puis lui dit
que c'est un chiffre le démesuré un
genre de 50% le au mastic à 38 50 % des
séparations arrive de deux à trois ans
après la chute d'un d'un immeuble
immobilier dans le fond la promesse je
sois d'une maison d'un condo parce que
y'a trop d'avoir le sait le stress au
quotidien surtout si tu retable le truc
qui tue fédérer no et le stress
financier qui vient d'émettre une corde
au cou aussi publié il ya pas beaucoup
de plus gros de plus gros et du soir de
relations qu'un stress financier et
après ça c'est comme tout sauf existait
une vraie statistiques loeb c'est fou
quand tu passes au sol
ce que star parce que tous leurs frais
ou t'attendrai non non je leur ai dit
nourrit toujours jeudi
si je prends pas dire que c'est une des
choses qui fait que mon mois et demi
qu'on est plus ensemble sauf que il y
avait quand d'autres échouent use le
fait qu est ce que je pense que ça les
cartes double coeur que si on n'avait
pas acheté on sait on allait passer une
audience en bleu aujourd'hui même si
j'adore mon type explique je suis
tellement fier de toutes les choses
qu'on a réussi à accomplir et enfants ou
un homme comme non je le fais 100 pour
100 km
et j'avais avec evans de chine ma course
ma nouvelle collègue qui espère bien que
mon ex juste pas que eux aussi savent à
quel point et ces six zones et au shag
merci mais on prêt de retrouver le sait
juste à côté du he bei juste à côté pour
trouver ma maison à m'essayer proche du
métro et un macbook blanc j'ai encore
une façon de mettre au fait que comme
corde mais ouais lima bien on s'assoit
pas plus je veux pas te mettre de la
pression sur le franc fort mais ça sera
pas plus facile même prochaines années
avec avec le kabyle apparemment que la
situation de l'immobilier va susceptible
si je me rase tout du tout winner quoi
français la relaxe et peut-être ouais
ouais merci beaucoup tête ouverte avec
nous autres et ça fait plaisir mais j'ai
l'impression que je crois que j'ai
redoublé après ces sports de fin de
rencontre aidé à m'en aille